voilà
[Musique]
[Musique]
1 me
voilà un crime horrible qui n'est pas
fait pour encourager mon rayonnement on
dit que ce jour monsieur lanfrey grand
buveur d'eau de vie et de piquette avait
aussi pris de verre d'absinthe
par la suite on appris aussi que sa
femme était enceinte de quatre mois sans
procès n'a pas réussi à mettre d'accord
les autorités sur les causes réelles de
sa folie les uns accusent le rôle
évident de l'absinthe
les autres dont le procureur remarquer
qu'il n'avait vu que deux ans d'absinthe
avant le meurtre
mais la roue du mauvais sort était en
marche lanfrey accusé d'un quadruple
meurtre fut condamné à 30 ans
d'emprisonnement il allait se pendre
trois jours plus tard tous les journaux
s'intéressèrent au meurtre à l'absinthe
une pétition circule à dans le canton de
vaud pour réclamer ma prohibition 30
4375 hommes et 48 1075 femme réclame r
mon interdiction immédiate dans ce pays
même où je suis né à quelques lieues de
la voici à peine plus d'un siècle
[Musique]
e
c'est là que tout avait commencé j'étais
en ce temps là très apprécié pour mes
vertus thérapeutiques tonique stimulante
apéritive insectifuges dur éthique dit
en deux mois dans un papyrus égyptien
datant de 1600 avant notre ère qui du dr
ordinaire originaire de franche-comté ou
de la mer henriot fut le découvreur de
l'absinthe la légende se plaît à mêler
la paternité du breuvage installé en
suisse dans le val de travers pour
échapper à la révolution française
monsieur pierre ordinaires ne dédaignait
pas les panacée il en employait une en
particulier
l'élixir d'absinthe un composé de
plantes aromatiques dont il avait seul
le secret bien des gens après en avoir
fait usage se déclaraient radicalement
guéri à la mort du docteur sa
gouvernante bandits la formule ofi du
lieutenant henriot qu ils exploitèrent
commercialement on dit aussi qu'à cette
époque vivaient ici une vieille femme
appelée la mère henriot dans les potions
et est célèbre et qui confectionnait
semaine l'élixir mais les amateurs de
vars plus nombreux que les malades
le majeur du billet acheté la recette
il montait alors la première fabrique
d'absinthe en 1797
il lança l'élixir sur le marché
la même année sa fille se maria avec
henri louis pernot en heure de gloire
s'annonçait
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
là sont croisés l' égard sont trois
perroquets et bien qu'aucune option vous
laissez reposer quelques jours elle est
prête à recevoir les carrières suis
moche à éditer bêtise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le jour dit
[Musique]
je suis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
audio
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
attendu que l'afld saint lô et criminels
provoque l'épilepsie et la tuberculose
et quelques chaque année des milliers de
france attendu qu'elle fait de l'homme
une bête féroce de la femme une martyre
de l'enfant un dégénéré qu elle
désorganise héroïne la famille et menace
ainsi l'avenir du pays
attendu peur des mesures de défense
spécial s'impose impérieusement à la
france qui boite à elle seule plus de 5
que le reste du monde
nous invitons le parlement a voté une
proposition de loi interdisant dans le
plus bref délai la fabrication la vente
en gros et au détail de la fin
vous êtes abonné
l'absinthe et 246 fois plus susceptibles
que le vin d'être cause de troubles et
trois fois plus coupables que tout
alcools distillés la véritable
caractéristiques de l'absinthe
c'est de mener directement à la gilles
ou au tribunal
[Applaudissements]
nous n'attaquons pas l'heure de
l'apéritif
ce moment agréable de détendre nous
attaquons l'érosion de la défense
nationale
la pollution de l'absence et la défense
nationales vont de pair
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est nécessaire c'est une guerre
de tranchées contre la fatigue
[Applaudissements]
quatre mille personnes avaient assisté à
ce meeting du 14 juin 1907 au dehors la
chronique deal une contre manifestation
tout aussi nombreuses et emportés par le
député giraud de pontarlier scandaient
son hostilité
[Musique]
mais vous entendez ça ils veulent notre
mort ou bien comment je fais marcher de
commerce mois ci commence à interdire
tout ce qui se vend bien et aussi le
parlement il s'emmêle de mal à séduire
le pays mais stop de toutes les
campagnes que nous avons entreprises
pour la salubrité publique
aucune ne nous a procuré autant de
fierté que cette bataille contre
l'absinthe meurtrières dans la grande
salle du trocadéro comble jusqu'au fait
c'est le coeur de la france que nous
avons senti batterie hier soir plus de
4000 personnes étaient accourues à notre
appel pour entendre les hommes éminents
qui devait dénoncer les méfaits de la
fée mongrain l'hymne national éclater a
clamé par des centaines de voix que
soutenait de vibrantes fanfare alors
les orateurs concept à paris écoutez ce
que monsieur prudhomme
il faut tu es là tu restes d'autres
livre vert or j'ai vécu là mais heures
les plus sombres dans le midi la révolte
des viticulteurs et est devenu une
véritable affaire politique
croyez vous que je sois pour quelque
chose dans les malheurs du languedoc et
du roussillon
rappelez vous ces manifestations à
narbonne à montpellier à perpignan
victime de la surproduction et surtout
de l'engouement pour les boissons
apéritives dont certaines étaient de
vrais piquette tous les producteurs s'en
prennent à moi et conseils municipaux et
généraux émir des voeux anti absinthe
hic on m'avait prise comme boucs
émissaires dans cette affaire alors
qu'on ne voulait pas s'attaquer à
l'alcoolisme
il faut dire que la viticulture
française faisait vivre près de 8
millions de personnes
sale temps voulait un monsieur anthony
affaires vie vers les attends moi ce
soir
matt unis maîtresse tout à l'espoir
d'avoir ta caresse je me suis assis au
banc à café mes yeux inquiets vion de
l'intérêt sauva y vient
rayan chaque fois de voir arriver tout
en attendant j'ai pris un verre
d'absinthe l'heure où tu devais venir
teinte
tu n'es pas là on verrait vide une autre
absente qui permet que je lise indiqué
paient l'eau tombant vers très lente à
goutte et mon coeur ou tel bien tomber
le doute pose des questions touchant et
touba garde en commun leurs vins
d'espérance tandis que le soir sans
grisaille il pense au deuil de ma nuit
qui ne vient pas tout en attendant j'ai
pris deux absents venez passer une autre
heure interviennent encore mon verre
évident
une autre absente c'est bien dit c'est
l'ivresse provoquée par la boisson et
engendre la poésie
une comptine
[Musique]
voilà en quel état ils m'ont mise les
ligues antialcooliques les viticulteurs
les hautes autorités de la république
tous unis contre moi pour distille
sauver la france du péril vert ils
étaient des dizaines de milliers à
défendre leur vin et signer des
pétitions
tous ces gens là ne boivent pas beaucoup
d'absinthe
comment peuvent-ils m'en vouloir sa
petite île le secret de ma fabrication
que koné style de mon histoire
[Musique]
troisièmement sonna de la trompette et
il tomba du ciel une grande étoile
ardente comme un flambeau et elle tomba
sur le tiers des fleurs et sur les
sources d eau
le nom de cette étoile est absinthe et
le tiers des eaux puis changer en
absinthe et beaucoup d'hommes moururent
par les eaux parce qu'elle était devenu
amer
je suis la grande absinthe
on m'appelle la luynes l'albine l'herbe
sainte l'herbe aux vierges où l'herbe
ouvert au sens étymologique le mot grec
absinthium signifie qu'il est impossible
de boire ou encore privé de douceur à la
vérité il faut avoir foi en mon
efficacité pour supporter cette amertume
pline l'ancien dans son histoire
naturelle vente mes qualités curatives
durant le haut moyen-âge
on buvait le vin d'absinthe pour
combattre la jaunisse
j'étais aussi le remède contre les
angines la flamme à sion des paupières
et les rages de dents
at on oublié tous les bienfaits c'est au
xviiie siècle tout a changé de médical
je suis devenu apéritif ici pour me
confectionner un cultivait sur de
grandes étendues l'hysope la grande et
la petite absinthe en est et où le
val-de-travers embaumait de mai senteurs
puissante les champs colorés de bleu les
villages environnants les femmes s'user
les yeux et les genoux à extirper la
mauvaise herbe
il fallait que la récolte plus vierge
avant d'être entreposés au séchoir
[Applaudissements]
est venu le t2 1ère cat et vont aussi
dans ce grand navire ahts bien
franchement buvaient modérément
l'absinthe cardozo rien n'est aussi mots
très durs et modérément la carrière ou
non rien n'est pas si on faisait sans
doute nuls debout n'ignore que bien des
gens vont pousser et la main en
entendant affirmé que j'honore second
concours classe dans les aurains la
réalité dédaigne 7e place
elle s'assit
j'ai vite en règle dont on les voit à
calomnie et l'absinthe carnet ont bon
dos rien n'est aussi bon on ne croit pas
qu'un lobby et la sainte marienne au
monde où rien n'étant simon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
content
pas
[Musique]
enfin
j'ai tourné le dos c'est ainsi que
risque de vous traiter les quais les
sociétés de tempérance si vous continuez
à prendre ce cher breuvage rappelle-toi
ce que disait ce grand buveur de jarry
cet acrobate délais cet amateur de pissy
plaît tellement l'interné les anti
alcoolique sont des malheureux sous
l'emprise de l'eau ce poison terrible si
corrosif et si seulement qu'entre toutes
les substances
c'est elle qui a été choisie pour les
leasings donné les moyens une seule
goutte d'eau ajoutez les kids limpide
comme l'absinthe le trouble
un coup de vent là comme dirait grimod
de la reynière notre fin gastronome pour
maigrir sur la tête
absinthe veut d'abord de laper l'eau
frappé les diamants sont témoin l'eau
tiède
il n'en faut pas jupiter la condamnent
toi même qu'en dis-tu autant voudrait ma
foi boire du peace and du bouillon
pointu il n'allait pas commenter ce
oreilles du hanovre surtout maulévrier
avec mon retard le croire et la pauvre
près l'on veut la nouille dérider la
toujours une première goutte
là bas on verrait alors palpiter vibrer
tout sourire ingénument
mesdames messieurs en 1826
l'arrondissement de pontarlier comptait
4 10 il rit par suite de l'engouement
des consommateurs
elle s'étend dire dans les départements
voisins de la haute saône et du jura les
distilleries je multiplie les marques
rivalisent r mais comme nous pernod et
fils du 20 10 juneau berger et
l'agriculture à ce moment
s'approvisionne les à l'envi le procédé
que nous utilisons ici est celui de la
destination
pour cela on choisit les plantes ils
sont renfermés dans ces gros ballots
pour laiteries ont laissé et on l'est
pèse santé le parfum qui s'en échappe
il vous êtes provient de sa chloride
encore 3,5
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rio a stagné
aller au bout
c'est bon vous rajoutez les autres c'est
bien c'est bon selon la régie son alcool
et les convient de distinguer les
absinthes inférieure est normal les
absinthes supérieur l'absinthe suisse
est l'une des meilleures d'après charles
berger la recette originale de
l'absinthe suisse versé pernaut il faut
exiger le plus grand soin dans le choix
des substances et des plantes destinées
de sa coloration pour un rendement de
120 litres titre en 72 degrés ce
qu'alice exigé pour les fondations on
mélange de l'alcool reprend 1,7 degré 92
etr exactement 90 et litres d'eau 14 kg
dany 4 kg 500 de fenouil de kilos saint
saëns de grande synthe 150 g 2010 sans
album de korian pour la couleur mon insu
200 litres extrait blanc 2 1 sur 12 kg
de petite absinthe et quatre kilos
disent oh c'est le lac taureau fils je
proviens cette couleur verte
[Musique]
ce dimanche 11 août 1901 restera dans
toutes les mémoires
la terrible orage éclata la foudre
touche l bâtiment fable écolo comme
partout les bouteilles explosait sous la
force de la channel les milliers de
litres d'absents brûlante se déversèrent
dans le doubs la rivière qui coloraient
d'une teinte laiteuse jaune vert à
pernod est notre père à tous qui fera
très loin mon nom depuis les hauteurs du
doubs jusqu'aux territoires les plus
reculés de la terre henri-louis le
premier de la dig s avait installé cette
fabrique un charlie en 1805 sous le nom
de maison pernaut fils il sortait 16
litres par jour
avec ses 2 à l'envi cent ans plus tard
les bâtiments pernaut fils abritait 60
alambic et produisait en moyenne 40
mille hectolitres de frais d'ape 5 par
an après l'incendié
on reconstruit une usine très modernes
en matière de politique sociale
l'entreprise était aussi tout à fait
d'avangard participation aux bénéfices
retraite aux enfants de assurance contre
les accidents du travail et même une
indemnité contre le chômage
millions de lits d'absinthe était
d'éviter annuellement prend 1000
personnes travaillaient pour l'absinthe
et donc je suis dans un canton qui
comptait environ 15000 habitants
je vais vous dire la grandeur de cette
entreprise l'objet était connu dans le
monde entier
peu de monde buvait la traîne
et ce programme est exportée jusqu'à
l'infini
c'est ainsi qu'on buvait de l'absinthe
haïti à madagascar achats et donc
comment la nouvelle orléans c'était
l'apéritif idéal
[Musique]
moore
toutes les armes
vraiment à chanter
[Musique]
la ville
m
quoi
[Musique]
mais jacques chantage wireless a craqué
à la chambre de mon plaisir
j'en vois trois points
[Musique]
mais en bas du jour mais la guinée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis la fée verte ma robe et couleurs
d'espérance
je n'ai rien de commun avec l'effet du
temps passé ce suprise et autant par des
hommes que par les femmes
malgré toutes ses faveurs l'histoire
s'est retourné contre moi
peut-être parce qu'on m'avait choisie
pour adoucir le péché originel
au même moment où manet composer son
buveur d'absinthe
il y à ce jeune journaliste auteur d'un
ouvrage consacré à l'absinthe et aux
absinthe heures qui proclame la femme à
6000 avec une facilité remarquable tous
ceux qui en bien ou en mal agi
violemment sur son organisation
essentiellement impressionnable
soyez-en persuadé s'il y a des absinthes
eux c'est que préalablement il y a eu
des absinthes heures l'absinthe omani
est en effet essentiellement contagieuse
c'est par l'homme que le mal a été
transmis à la femme
combien de peintres et de poètes et
j'inspire et manet degas et
toulouse-lautrec avaient été les
premiers à venir et les charmes dans
leur table domi avait su me distinguer
dans de belles caricature van gogh et
picasso m' ont représenté dans mes plus
belles parures musset et baudelaire me
voulait une belle adoration paul
verlaine charles cros m'ont rendu un
hommage inoubliable alfred jarry oscar
wilde et arthur rimbaud tremper leurs
lèvres et des rêveries s'échapper de
leur plume
[Musique]
avec les senneurs les femmes avec
l'absinthe avec le feu on peut se
divertir un peu joué son rôle en
quelques drames l'absinthe bu un soir
d'hiver est clair envers l'âme en fumée
et les fleurs sur la bien aimée
embaument devons le feu clair puis les
baisers perdre leur charme ayant duré
trop de saison est réciproque trahison
font qu'on se quitte un jour sans larmes
on brûle lettres et bouquets le feu se
mettent à l'alcool et si la triste vie
et sauver reste l'absinthe et c'est ok
les portraits sont mangés de flammes les
doigts crispés son tremblotant on meurt
d'avoir dormi longtemps avec les fleurs
avec les femmes
[Musique]
on
non
alors l'état où tous les
photo
à
venu chercher des poltrons me marie avec
des motos
le 10 le cac
[Musique]
bonjour
g
[Musique]
et
voilà bien que les médecins s'occupent
de l'absinthe et les viticulteurs ils
veulent sa peau ce qui n'allait pas
écouler leurs geagea pikit est ce que
c'est de notre faute à nous il a besoin
des bonnes et meilleur marché
dans le même temps ou l'absinthe
conquiert sa popularité
les ferments du mouvement anti
alcoolique vont prendre définitivement
en france les questions d'hygiène et
plus encore de santé morale de la nation
s'ajouteront aux intérêts économiques et
politiques pour amplifier la grande
contre les mauvais alcool
on appellera à la rescousse les plus
hautes personnalités de la république
les artistes les médecins les
instituteurs pour jeter le discrédit sur
l'absinthe ce fléau national frappe
plusieurs millions de personnes
près d'un français sur dix victor tu
veux passer au tableau pour nous livre
la leçon d'aujourd'hui
quiconque s'adonnent à l'alcool perd ses
facultés à sa dignité
il néglige sa femme et ses enfants il
cède à l'attrait du cabaret et la misère
règne en son intérieur
l'alcool n'est pas un aliment c'est un
poison avec lui la délinquance et la
criminalité progresse il trouve la
raison de l'ouvrier relatant à la haine
il entraîne à dire la dégénérescence
victor la dégénérescence du buveur et de
sa descendance les enfants disent
alcooliques sont souvent idiot vous
comprenez maintenant les ravages de
l'alcool qui veut continuer la leçon oui
martin at war
lebron ya toujours sa bouteille
d'absinthe la terrible les gars qui
anime ses forces avaient étendre son
intelligence qu'on a brillé vous à
l'absinthe infâme la mer empoisonneurs
sur toutes les tables on a beau nu
prêcher la tempérance il répond qu'on
veut le priver des plaisirs dans les
riches ne se prive pas refait martin
gardez bien en mémoire ce que disait le
président casimir perier en inaugurant
le premier congrès anti alcoolique en
1903 l'alcool est un merveilleux agents
de lumière et de force
ce que nous demandons c'est qu'on n'en
remplissent les lampes les réservoirs
des automobiles les foyers des
chaudières et qu'on ne verse pas dans
les estomacs
oh
[Musique]
ça fait 6 ou oui bah tu dire à ton père
que je fais pas crédible bon allez il à
ce point la bouteille à l'académie de
médecine depuis 1903 un groupe de
spécialistes s'est constituée pour
étudier la nocivité des sens aussi
variés que l'absinthe la thuyone l'anis
et autres substances entrant dans la
fabrication et la distillation de
certaines liqueur comme d'autres de
leurs collègues auparavant ils ont testé
sur les animaux et l'homme
l'absorption massive de l'une ou l'autre
leur conclusion sera décisive pour
relayer l'action du mouvement anti
alcoolique et inciter le gouvernement à
prendre des mesures énergiques pour
enrayer ce que chacun s'accorde à
considérer comme un fléau les
différentes essences d'absinthe
artificiel ou naturel dans la borde
mes chers collègues
on a vu nous sommes rassemblés en ce
jour pour étudier la toxicité de
certaines essences et plus
particulièrement celle de l'absinthe qui
est la plus dangereuse surtout
lorsqu'elle est accompagnée d'alcool dès
1859 la thèse de leurs confrères mottet
démontrer les désordres engendrés par la
liqueur d'absinthe à la différence des
autres boissons alcooliques en 1868
les travaux du docteur magnan déterminé
que l'absorption de l'essence d'absinthe
par voie orale sous cutanée ou
intraveineuse expériences réalisées sur
des animaux
provoquer des convulsions au coeur de
l'essence d'absinthe
nous avons pu relever que la thuyone
était le principal agent responsable de
la toxicité
cependant nous ne pouvons ignorer sans
contester l'ensemble de ces travaux que
le docteur magnan était obsédé par par
le trouble de l'alcool sur la santé
morale de ses congénères il n'est pas
loin de considérer tout absent à tisme
comme une forme de maladie mentale
or nous savons nous le savons que les
physiologistes cadéac et meuniers ont
abouti à des conclusions beaucoup moins
unanimes ils ont été jusqu'à
expérimenter sur eux mêmes les effets
une absorption massive d'essence
d'absinthe avec une dose d'un gramme
soit l'équivalent d'une quantité
contenue dans 200 verre d'absinthe
ordinaire et n'ont constaté aucun
phénomène du type perte de mémoire ou
troubles intérieurs
rien n'égale les ravages causés par la
liqueur l'absinthe et je vais vous le
démontrer s'il vous plaît outre les
accidents habituel de l'alcoolisme
na li qu'un d'absinthe qui agit à la
fois comme alcool et je vous le rappelle
comme une huile essentielle tout à fait
spécial la liqueur d'absinthe rock
brutalement en état de stupeur et
d'habitudes qui usent les facultés
intellectuelles et qui précipite
l'avancée de la démence c'est
incontestablement le poison le plus
énergique qui soient mis à la
disposition des populations
la nation attend de nous une position
sérieuse
je vous rappellerai les travaux du dr
lahlou qui a pu déterminer que
l'absinthe est plus nocif sur les corps
appauvri que sur les être bien portant
il s'agit donc bien là d'une question de
morale on mettra sans doute en cause la
pureté des alcools dont les industriels
sont responsables mais nous devons
néanmoins qualifié l'essence d'absinthe
comme la reine des poisons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon interdiction fut déclaré le 22
février 1906 en belgique puis le 7
octobre 1910 en suisse d'autres pays
dont la hollande prirent des mesures
similaires en france
après de multiples débats et
contre-propositions
selon les intérêts des uns et les autres
le combat pour l'abolition de l'absinthe
trouvera une feinte opportune dans le
déclenchement du premier conflit mondial
dès l'ouverture des hostilités au nom de
l' équilibre sanitaires et morale des
armées le gouvernement militaire puis
les préfets prohibe air l'absinthe
région par région décision que confirma
la loi du 16 mars 1915 les buveurs de la
verte iront remplir les salles d'asile
et d'hôpitaux sans qu'on résolve
sérieusement les dégâts engendrés par un
alcoolisme de plus grande envergure
[Musique]
non
l'absinthe a fait place à la nuisette au
pastis de l'italien pasticcio et
signifie situation trouble même
étiquette même bouteille mêmes arômes le
degré d'alcool s'est stabilisé à 45°
l'industrie de l'apéritif anisé s'est
rapproché de la méditerranée aucune
expérience scientifique n'a pu prouver
la toxicité de cette macération
mais le goût de l'absinthe sont
définitivement perdus
excepté dans quelconque à bâle en suisse
où le culte de conduite vous a poussé si
la dette est la fabrique et plein
d'espoir
si vous voulez me déguster sans cacher
derrière quelques cloisons
sachez qu'on me trouve en espagne sous
le nom d'apps nta vous souvenez du grec
absinthium c'était vraiment joué de
malchance
si je suis amère qu'elle pallem
consolera
[Musique]
plus
oh
les